et ce temps fort au sénat aujourd'hui
lolli l'audition d'olivier véran par
cette commission denquête coville les
sénateurs l'ont longuement interrogé
donc sur le durcissement des mesures
annoncées hier soir mais aussi et
surtout peut-être sur son rôle dès son
arrivée aux responsabilités
oui olivier ferrand c'est un ministre
qui est né dans la crise sanitaire
c'était un inconnu du grand public et il
s'est révélé aux yeux des français à
partir du 16 février dernier
ce jour-là agnès buzyn lui passe le
témoin à elle elle quitte le ministère
de la santé pour battre la campagne des
municipales à paris et lui c'est un
médecin député de l'em2 l'isère et ils
se trouvent ils se retrouvent propulsés
aux manettes de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire est donc face aux sénateurs ce
matin olivier vers on n'a pas oublié de
préciser ses conditions d'arrivée un
petit peu particulière il succède à
agnès buzyn alors que le virus s'emballe
sur tout le territoire
une situation qui est loin d'être
idyllique donc et vous allez l'entendre
il tacle en creux celle qui l'a précédée
écouter cet extrait je suis arrivé au
moment où un point de non retour avait
déjà été atteint ce point de non retour
c'est la circulation du virus ce sont
des foyers épidémiques déjà constitués
et qui allait devenir peu contrôlable et
que nous n'étions pas alors on capacité
de connaître à l'époque
alors rassurez vous je ne suis pas là
pour me défausser sur qui que ce soit je
ne suis pas là pour vous dire que somme
toute nous avons fait ce que nous avons
pu avec les moyens du bord je suis là
parce que nous devons toutes et tous
apprendre d'une crise qui a placé la
santé publique au coeur de nos
préoccupations et quelques minutes plus
tard un numéro d'équilibriste du
ministre là il vient de dire vous l'avez
entendu que la situation du pays et la
situation sanitaire du pays était
presque incontrôlable à son arrivée mais
il va affirmer devant les sénateurs que
grâce au travail d'agnès busan la france
était finalement mieux préparés que ses
voisins européens écoutez le préparation
du système de santé je le dis et je
rends hommage à l'action qui a été
conduite par ma prédécesseure elle était
réelle et je peux vous dire madame la
ministre que lorsqu'elle vous dit en
commission d'enquêté hier qu'elle était
sans doute la mieux préparée des pays
environnants niveau d' alerte était
important en france comparé à beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de quoi sans qui nous
entoure alors outre ces références agnès
buzyn auditionné hier au sénat sur le
fond des échanges
les sénateurs n'ont pas
ménagés olivier verrons non ça c'est sur
l'audition a duré 3 heures 10 les
questions étaient précises les remarques
nombreuses
la rapporteure heller catherine de roche
a regretté par exemple le manque
d'autocritique du ministre ainsi que ses
prédécesseurs bernard jomier qui est lui
rapporteur ps de la commission denquête
à lui émis olivier ferrand sur le grill
pointant les ratés du fameux triptyque
vous savez tester tracé isolés que le
gouvernement a longtemps prôné le
ministre a évidemment dû rendre des
comptes sur le sujet le plus polémique
de la crise les stocks de masques pour
olivier ferrand seul l'avancé des
recommandations scientifiques notamment
de celle de l' oms a guidé le
gouvernement dans ses choix de ne pas
distribuer au grand public est selon lui
en aucun cas ce n'est la pénurie qui a
dicté la doctrine de l'état écoutez je
ne fais pas de lien entre la pénurie de
masques et la doctrine d'utilisation des
matches je suis arrivé comme ministre il
n'y avait plus eu le mal était fait en
matière de stocks de masques
si j'avais dû dire aux français on
aurait dû vous donner des masses mois en
a pas je leur ai dit est ce que je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas eu les stocks
de masques suffisant pour protéger des
soignants les hôpitaux les médecins etc
oui évidemment évidemment est ce que si
j'avais eu 2 milliard de masques en
stock on en aurait distribué à la
population jeu nettement sur la base des
recommandations dont on dispose
je ne vois pas pourquoi on le fait et
l'autre critiques adressées par les
parlementaires à l'unisson c'est la
lenteur des décisions prises par les
autorités au plus fort de la crise le
ministre passablement agacé s'est
justifié sur le sujet à tous on fait
gaffe à tous
quand des masques arrivent de chine même
si vous a manqué sur le territoire
voulait distribuer pas si la douane n'a
pas vérifié que les masques sont
conformes et efficace et efficient et ça
prend des jours et ça prend des jours
entre le moment où vous décidez de
quelque chose et le moment où la chose
est opérationnel efficace ça prend des
jours nous avons un système
particulièrement normatif en france nous
avons fait sauter un paquet de normes
qui était illusoire et dérisoire pendant
la période
il m'arrivait signé des décrets d
arrêter à tour de bras pour simplifier
les choses mais que voulez vous il ya
des choses qui prennent du temps je
croyais moi je le regrette
au moins autant que vous et puis
jonathan la particularité de l'édition
du jour c'est qu'olivier ferrand est
toujours en exercice
ouais il est non seulement en exercice
et surtout la crise
elle n'est pas terminée le ministre a
donc été assailli de questions sur sa
décision prise hier de durcir les
mesures sanitaires à marseille ou en
guadeloupe des décisions qui font
actuellement polémique on en a parlé un
peu plus tôt dans cette édition
parce que les élus locaux dénoncent le
nouveau tour de vis décidés par paris
sans concertation avec les collectivités
sur le terrain